it is that time of the year where you
begin to start thinking more about
losing weight getting fit staying
healthy so daniel magyar the sponsor of
this segment is here to tell us about
how to properly diet and what foods to
eat when trying to prevent plateau so
let's first and foremost define
preventing plateau for everybody
so the plateau is basically a metabolic
adaptation that means that a body has
adapted
to consume
basically so consuming low calories for
a long period of time so it doesn't burn
the excess of energy as it used to
before so many people call it slower
metabolism so that's a metabolic
adaptation okay and what's your
background because obviously you know
what you're talking about you i actually
don't feel uh tall
next to you you're a personal trainer
yes i'm a personal trainer and uh
basically the best way to lose weight
without the plateau you have to set up
the diet proper way so you have to have
a certain days in a week that you
consume more calories and those calories
should be equal to the calories that you
burn a day actually at the metabolite
rate that will be the high tolerance day
so we got some high quality protein over
here some steak and some burger
some good complex carbohydrates which is
the sweet potato some sugars that we use
after the workouts and also some rice
you know the eggs is the most absorbable
protein all treated on the butter
now for the weight loss day this is all
for the uh for the high tail already now
for the low power day when you actually
lose their weight that's a low calorie
day right here exactly so you would
start four days a week on this meal plan
which would be matching you're at the
metabolic rate then you transition three
days a week to the low calorie day and
that treats the weight loss wow see you
wouldn't see this big steak and think
low calorie day so
the low calorie days on a calorie
deficit ideally 200 calories below
you're based on a tablet rate
still will be a little bit a little bit
of food that you have to consume and
that food has to be nutrient dense which
is the eggs of course the steak and some
butter to cook with
to know and what about fasting this is
something that people do but a lot of
people don't understand how to do it
properly so on the high calorie day you
don't fast you consume breakfast lunch
and dinner on a low calorie day you fast
for 23 hours so you basically fast the
whole day and you eat one big meal
and that's going to deliver the fasting
benefits which is the excessive
production of a growth hormone and um
when that's one big meal um it's really
upset convenience okay okay yeah it
could be a lunch time i'm a lunch guy so
i mostly at lunch okay dinner time i
don't recommend eating four to five
hours before you go to bed because that
might cost
some insomnia might keep you awake
during the night exactly well thank you
so much daniel this is good tips very
good tape tips um so you can find him on
instagram at dm underscore trainer and
10 off online coaching program as well
thank you for that thanks for all these
tips jillian i'll send it to you